معنا من السوق المركزي في جنوب الخرطوم
ومراسل الجزيره محمد الطيب محمد كيف تمر
هذه الساعات بعد الاعلانيه عن هدنه
واتهامات متبادله بخرقها
نعم عثمان نحن الان في
الصحافه الشرق وبالتحديد بالقرب من مستشفى
ابراهيم مالك هذا المستشفى التعليمي الذي
ترونه خلفي واحد من اهم المستشفيات في
منطقه جنوب الخرطوم ويخدم اكثر من عشره
احياء
اساسيه في هذه المنطقه هناك
عدد كبير جدا من المرضى والذين يريدون
يستشفون يتعالجون في هذا المركز في هذه
المستشفى لكن هذا المستشفى
مغلق تماما هذه احدى الجثث التي لم ترفع
حتى هذه اللحظه
لا ندري لمن تعود هذه الجثه قال لنا الناس
الموجودين في هذه المنطقه ان هذه الجثه
لاحد الاشخاص توفي في هذه المنطقه ولا
يعلم ما هي اسباب وفاتها بحسب ما نقلوا
لنا المستشفى مغلق بالكامل
ليست هناك طواقم طبيه الكهرباء مقطوعه عن
هذا المستشفى منذ اندلاع الاحداث تحدث
الناس الذين
يعني هذا مشهد ربما لا يجب ان نمر عليه
بهذه السرعه هذا مشهد قاسي للغايه محمد في
بلد مثل الخرطوم مثل السودان وفي العاصمه
الخرطوم
يعني انا شخصيا كنت اسمع عن انتشار جثث
على قارعه الطريق ولكن هذه اول مره ربما
بالنسبه لي اشاهدها معك في شرح هذا يعني
مشهد قاسي للغايه
نعم قضيه
الجثث البلقاء في الواقع
ربما تكون لاسباب حتى الان لا نعلم سبب
يعني موت هذا الشخص بالتحديد
لكن لاول مره حقيقه في تجوالنا في مناطق
مختلفه
نلاحظ جثه في طريقنا وفي حركتنا لكن نعود
الى قضيه المستشفيات قضيه المستشفيات قضيه
مشكله كبيره جدا لان المناطق الجنوبيه
للعاصمه تكاد اغلب المستشفيات التي مررنا
بها مستشفى الشيخ ومستشفى الجوده
مستشفيات عده من ضمنها هذا المستشفى
التعليمي الذي يعتبر من اكبر المستشفيات
هنا في جنوب الخرطوم ويخدم عدد كبير من
الناس هناك مشاكل تواجه الاطهم الطبيه هي
كيفيه الوصول الى المستشفى وتقديم هذه
الخدمات في ظل عدم امان على سلامتهم هناك
مشاكل متعلقه بالوقود لتشغيل الكهرباء في
هذه المستشفى بالاضافه الى مشاكل متعلقه
بتوفر
العلاج الاكسجين ما الى ذلك من قضايا هذه
الاشياء تجعل هذه المستشفيات خارجه عن
الخدمه تماما وبالتالي سكان هذه المناطق
عموما يعانون من هذه المشكله امامنا الان
عدد من المعامل والصيدليات والعيادات
هي مغلقه بالكامل بسبب الصراع بسبب
الاشتباكات التي تقع من حين الى اخر هذه
المنطقه نوعا ما نسبيا تعد امنه ليست فيها
اشتباكات او ليست هي قريبه نوعا ما من
الاشتباكات لكن حاله الذعر التي سيطرت على
المواطنين جعلتهم
جعلتهم يقللون من تحركاتهم كذلك الاطقم
الطبيه ليست ليس هناك من يقدم لها الحمايه
او يقدم لها
القدره على الوصول هناك مشاكل كما تحدثنا
عنها سابقا فيما يتعلق
الوقود قضيه الحركه في ظل انعدام الوقود
الجازولين والمنزين تجعل الحركه صعبه
اضافه الى ذلك قصه امان الناس في طريق
وصولهم الى هذه المستشفيات الحربيه فلذلك
قصه
المستشفيات
والقطاع الصحي هي من القضايا المهمه
والخطيره والتي يعاني منها اغلب الناس
فلذلك عمليه الاستضباب
صعبه وليست هي بالامر الساهل ليس بالامر
سهل على الاطلاق مثل امور كثيره ليست سهله
ولكن هذا امر اساسي وحتى اليوم سمعنا عن
سقوط قذيفه في مركز الرومي الطبي في في
هذه الدرجه وصلت الامور شكرا لك محمد
الطيب في جنوبي الخرطوم